blicain du sénat bonjour gérard larcher
bonjour emmanuel macron s'est exprimé en
exclusivité sur europe 1 sur le sujet de
l'immigration le président et entrer
vraiment dans les détails de ce débat
qu'il a lancée s'il rappelle le principe
d'humanité il pointe et ainsi sur
l'inefficacité des politiques de nos
politiques migratoires
vous partagez constat écoutez d'abord
c'est bien qu'ils soient adressés par
vous à tous les français pas simplement
à sa majorité dans un espace restreint
parce qu'on est sur un sujet que nous
devons partager
il faut en parler de manière apaisée
mais en vérité et bien sûr il s'agit
d'une question qui concerne des humains
et donc le faire avec nos valeurs mais
regardons le bilan des manuels macron
jamais autant de demandes d'asile + 22%
d'ailleurs en provenance d'autres pays
européens
il n'y a que 10 % des déboutés du droit
d'asile qui sont reconduits à la
frontière et 256000 titre de séjour
échec d'une politique migratoire en plus
échec de l'intégration
le classement ocde deux classements pisa
des enfants issus de l'immigration est
parmi les plus catastrophiques des pays
de l'union européenne ue ne dit que le
président ne peut pas se placer en tant
qu'observateur qu'il est un acteur et
qu'il attend d'eux un bilan maintenant
des actes le bilan est mauvais il n'a
pas commencé d'ailleurs qu'il y a jallet
2 on attend des actes
et c'est donc à l'aune des actus
rappelle que que le gouvernement le
président sont passés à côté à côté
d'une chance qui leur était offert par
le sénat quand françois noël du feu
buffet ferrée dans le cadre de la loi
colons un rapport dit il faut une
immigration maîtrisée - accueillir pour
mieux accueillir idy un droit d'asile
effectifs et une intégration réussie
tout est dans les propositions que ce
soit le remplacement d'ed médicale
d'état par une aide médicale d'urgence
justement peut-être ces moments de
changer en tel cas de prendre conscience
de cela pour le président sur le sujet
de la m e mails
chronique n'est pas question de la
supprimer mais il ouvre la porte
clairement à sa réforme gérard larcher
notamment sur le panier de soins ça
semble être la bonne piste pour vous
mais c'est une piste que nous avons voté
je le rappelle en 2010 bunko l'assemblée
va prendre
écoutez moi je suis comme un saint bien
connu qui s'appelle thomas
maintenant nous allons voir sur les
actes rendez vous sur les axes est une
question sérieuse et j'ajoute que la
dimension européenne et est très
importante
c'est une des politiques sur lequel on
attend aussi que les pays européens
construisent ensemble il faut aussi
renforcer les moyens de frontex dublin
ne marche pas je vois que les français
souhaiteraient la disparition de
schengen je crois que ce serait une
mauvaise chose la disparition de
schengen mais rendons schengen
réellement effectif
en tous les cas c'est une question
importante pour les français c'est aussi
une question importante pour l'europe et
j'aurai terminé par un mot en réunissant
les sénats d'afrique au mois de juin au
sénat
j'ai entendu président du sénat côte
d'ivoire dit en même temps cette
migration movie goutte à goutte de notre
sang et des meilleurs jeunes qui
pourraient contribuer à notre économie
bien sûr aussi la question du co
développement en afrique et du
codéveloppement vous avez parlé aussi
tout à l'heure en débit notre interview
d'intégration c'est un peu étonnant
gérard larcher parce que si on voit les
récents sondages sur l'immigration pour
60% des sondés les migrants constitue je
cite une menace pour 65% des français
ils pensent que l'immigration d'amal y
aura pas la situation du pays bref ils
sont très loin des préoccupations de
l'intégration pour eux vous savez
l'intégration c'est entrer dans une
communauté nationale pour former
communauté ou singuliers et je crois
qu'il faut aussi travailler autour de la
question de l'intégration
la première d intégration c'est d'abord
l'école la réussite à l'école qui permet
de devenir citoyen d'un pays parce que
la réalité c'est que l'immigration zéro
n'existera pas je pense en plus que
n'est pas souhaitable
il a raison quand même le président de
ne pas laisser ce sujet au rassemblement
national de
frais en pts et justement pour être
certain du système binaire ou lui ou le
rassemblement national et moi tout mon
travail politique c'est de proposer aux
français un espace qui rassemble le
centre et la droite
là ce sont les français dans les urnes
qui disent ils le décideront encore
faut-il que nous soyons en capacité de
leur parler et de retrouver le chemin de
leur confiance
c'est pour ça que je me suis engagé pour
retrouver cet espace je pense qu'à
gauche est vrai aussi pour la famille
social démocrate
marche arrière toute du gouvernement sur
la suppression de l'exonération de
cotisations patronales pour l'emploi à
domicile des plus de 70 ans alors je le
dis vous vous souriez déjà la mesure
aura tenu moins de 24 heures ces 24
heures de trop si je vous comprends bien
l'enjeu crois que ça illustre la méthode
de l'exécutif la méthode verticale vous
savez on décide un jour de réduire
l'aide personnalisée au logement de 5
euros on décide de désindexer les
retraites on décide de peser sur les
retraités un peu plus je crois que ça
illustre la méthode c'est cette méthode
qui n'est plus supportée par une partie
des français je pense que ça contribue à
nourrir ses peurs ses inquiétudes ses
angoisses ce rejet cette perte de
confiance dans la décision politique
ça rejoint la démarche parce que je
pense que la verticalité des eaux vers
le bas elle n'a pas commencé non plus il
ya quelques mois mais cette verticalité
aujourd'hui il faut l'inversé c'est le
sens de ma démarche conduite notamment
avec les territoires est ce que vous
faites un second tour des territoires
mais gérard larcher vous parler de peur
d'angoissé auprès des français d'une
méthode rejetée par par nos concitoyens
mais alors pourquoi la droite ne saisit
pas sa chance pourquoi on n'entend pas
davantage l'opposition que vous incarnez
tous les cas vous m'écoutez vous
m'entendez oui ça fait je les écoute et
vous entendez le sénat quand il
s'exprime je crois que la peur des
français d'abord c'est que leurs enfants
vivent moins bien qu'eux mais qu'est ce
que vous leur proposez aux d'adieu
attendez dans mes déplacements qu'est ce
que je constate la montée de la
paupérisation qui n'est pas que
financière qui est aussi morale des gens
qui ont le sentiment d'être éloigné en
fait des décisions abandonnés oubliés et
ces témoignages sur la montée de
paupérisation
ils sont j'allais dire extrêmement fort
regardez il ya des symptômes les petits
centre ville déserté ça aussi la peur et
le sentiment fort d'avoir agi pour leur
procès par une nouvelle et 10 g des
rasions 2d centralisation redonner au
pouvoir territorial la capacité
d'initiative d'inventer d'innover dans
ma tournée qui va se poursuivre demain
dans la région grand est sur le thème
europe et collectivités territoriales
ben je peux vous dire qu'il ya des
réussites locales vous écoutant j'ai
l'impression que vous faites aussi votre
grand débat permanent
non je fais des bacilles j'écoute je
partage et c'est pas les élus par nos
élus c'est les élus parlent avec les
citoyens les citoyens engagés dans le
monde économique dans le monde
associatif et tous ces citoyens là ils
ont beaucoup de choses à dire
vous parlez ce matin au micro d'europe 1
il ya d'autres qui parlent en dehors des
républicains et xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse à l'évidence à l'évidence en
compétition pour 2022 l'un des 2 reprend
une vraie alternative crédible à
emmanuel macron je pense que il y a des
richesses dans les familles du sol
pendant les nanos pardonnez moi je gère
mon engagement c'est et c'est d'ailleurs
ma position c'est que ces talents là
puis sept puis c'est merger et offrir
une alternative pour 2022 et quel est le
premier talent qui doit émerger et en
faut toujours un
voilà pourquoi sans penser que c'est la
solution miracle il faut que nous
mettions en place une procédure qui
permette alors qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne s'impose de manière indiscutable une
alternative au seul choix qui serait une
fois encore emmanuel macron où marine le
pen ça je ne peux pas me résoudre donc
vous êtes d'accord pour les primaires
c'est j'ai bien compris
ah c'est le retour de la machine à
perdre oui enfin la machine à perdre
était autre chose si on trouve une autre
méthode je suis prêt à prendre
moi ma seule ma seule mon seul objectif
c'est qu'on offre aux français une
alternative et qu'on offre la démocratie
cette capacité de choisir je ne me
résous pas à ce que les familles du
centre et de la droite ne soit pas
présent au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle d'ailleurs pour ça que
jacques chirac ait voulu l'ump ne
l'oublions pas merci gérard larcher
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
sur europe 1 est d'abord réagi en
exclusivité à lyn thériault également
exclusive sur europe 1 d' emmanuel
macron prix merci merci merci beaucoup
sonia mabrouk
rap